The Joe Rogan experience. How much difference is it?
Perspective wise when you're,
when you're in space and you're looking down on the earth that has gotta be the
ultimate mindfulness.
It's amazing. So that this is what I'm trying to do in life.
Like a couple of books, I've written some films I've done. Um,
seeing the earth. I remember early in my first flight, it was like, okay,
I'm in outer space. And my there's my planet over there. You know,
it was this profound thought that, wow, I'm not on the planet anymore.
And over, uh, over seven months in space, it never got old.
Like it was always like, man, earth is beautiful. It is this incredible planet.
Um, and so there's, so we could talk for hours about this,
but I think for me the biggest perspective change was, um,
I'm less of a black and white person now, like before I went into space,
I knew right. And wrong. And a lot of you, when you're young, you kind of,
you're black and white. As you get older, you get wiser and seeing the planet,
seeing the planet, it's like, yeah,
this thing's been around for a long time and it's going to be around for a long
time. So you probably don't need to get as uptight about, you know,
the day-to-day stress of life. And, um, it's, uh,
it just kinda put things in perspective. Like,
don't get too excited about the Kardashians or whatever the latest political
tweet was or whatever. Um, like, you know,
things are gonna go on for a long time.
And so that it helps put that in perspective in a big way.
It's interesting that at an actual physical perspective change, just being,
just being in a different place where you're looking down on it from a different
vantage point,
all the astronauts seem to say that it has this profound shift in how you think
of earth and how you think of humanity in general. Yeah.
You know, one of the interesting things I've been traveling since I was a kid,
I did some exchange, uh, programs and Finland and France, and in the air force,
I lived all around the world and whenever I would go to France or
Korea or wherever, it was like, all right, I'm in Korea.
And then I get back to this date. So I'm like, all right, I'm back,
back home in America or whatever.
And now when I travel and I've been traveling a lot last couple years,
I don't ever, I always feel like I'm home. Like it was a weird one,
one time I landed in the middle East and I remember thinking, I'm it.
I didn't think anything.
And that really struck me because it used to always be such a big deal wherever
I landed. I kind of feel like I'm home no matter where I'm at, which is wow.
Interesting. And that's from the space travel.
I, it is. Yeah. Wow. Yeah. I,
it wasn't conscious. I didn't like expect it or whatever. I just realized that,
Hey, I don't ever, I don't ever feel like I'm not at home. And my,
my crew mates, Samantha said something really profound. She said, um,
like you see earth and you can tell it's going around the sun. Like,
you can actually see the motion sometimes if you're watching stars and stuff,
and it's like, we're on this spaceship together.
So we ought to be crew mates and not just passengers. Yeah.
Like we all have to kind of take care of the planet and ourselves,
each other and stuff. Do.
You find that most of the,
or many of the astronauts share this similar perspective shift
that once you go up,
you do realize how weird it is that there are these tribal differences between
us.
Yeah. You're like, what the hell are we doing? I got a story about that.
But to be honest, we're probably not the best, um, communicators of emotion,
you know, like, you know, we're not necessarily all touchy, feely people,
but some of my close friends that we talk about this, there's a very,
there's a very similar perspective of, you know, we're all here on the,
on the planet together.
I was on my first flight on the shuttle and it was the fifth.
I remember it was the fifth night there. And I looked out,
we were going on the Mediterranean at night and you could see there's this like
U shape where there's Egypt and the Nile there's Israel and Syria and Lebanon
are right there. And there's Turkey and Greece.
And it's just a little area in Israel is this little thing that's surrounded
by Jordan and Lebanon, you know, they're all like right there.
And I remember thinking like, guys, what's the problem. And you're, you're,
you're literally living together on a postage stamp on this big planet. Yeah.
And it wasn't anything about Israel or the middle East specifically.
It was more like, why, why can we not get along? Because you all down here.
Yeah.
And the crazy thing is if you ask most people, their,
their position is they'll never be pieced in the middle East. So,
which is crazy.
Things after my flight. So I, we would,
they'd send us to Congress and we talked to congressmen and senators,
and I got the talk at the white house a couple years ago at the national space
council. And my message to them is always the same. It's always, you know,
two for a space program. It's not about the rocket science.
It's about the political science.
Like we gotta figure out politics to get things working well.
And whenever I go to the American Congress, they're always like, you're right.
It's exactly right. If it wasn't for those other, on the other side,
we can get this right.
Republicans Democrats all said that they all totally agreed with me.
And it was always the other guy's fault. There's a, there's a,
there's definitely a problem that is going to be tough to overcome.
Benefit. Would there be in getting those people in space?
Yeah. You know, people talk about that.
If only that leaders could go into space and I think for some of them it would
make an impact. And some of them, they wouldn't care. I mean, there's there.
Well,
the goal of politics and power is just to keep yourself in power and get more
stuff for yourself. And, you know, throughout human history, it's not normally,
you know, altruistic democracies that the way we run ourselves. Um,
so which that we need to move in that direction because that's the way life gets
better. But, um, I think som it would benefit in some it wouldn't.
Well, the thing is like,
nobody really wants the job that is balanced and healthy
and intelligent and has a good perspective for perspective, for humanity. Yeah.
The people that want the job, they want to be the King Poobah.
They want to be an Eagle dog. Yeah.
It's just a weird kind of person that wants that job.
It's uh, people are like, why don't you run for office? And, and I always say,
well, do you have, give me a fork, you have a fork.
Cause I want to stick that in mind because that would more fun than, you know,
you try and do something nice. And you're just getting nonstop,
hate mail and yeah.
Girlfriends from high school. That's testifying.
For Congress. This thing that happened 30 years ago. Yeah, exactly.
Some it's fascinating to me.
How many of the astronauts do have this incredibly profound
experience? Again,
just from the physical act of being above earth,
looking down on it where this perspective shift just kind of changes
your,
your overall thoughts about being in space and being a
part of humanity on this organic spaceship
in the universe,
rather than being like locked down in Chicago is clouds above use.
And didn't even think about space. You know,
dude stuck in traffic on your way to work every day, same grind. Every,
he gets stuck in this narrow-minded perspective,
almost every astronaut who discusses this says that it was a profound life
changing moment to look at earth from above.
Yeah. It was. And you know, I can close my,
if I'm in one of those like situations, you just close your eyes and it's like,
right now, the sun is rising somewhere.
That's the most beautiful thing you can't imagine it. You know, I try,
I took a lot of pictures. I did movies, but unless you see it with your eyes,
you know, you can't imagine how awesome it is.
So that takes the edge off the traffic you're having to wait on. And, um,
it does help. But the,
the thing is like taking that experience and sharing it with as many people as
possible.
Catch new episodes of the Joe Rogan experience for free only on Spotify,
watch back catalog J R E videos on Spotify,
including clips easily seamlessly switch between video
and audio experience on Spotify.
You can listen to the JRE in the background while using other apps and can
download episodes to save on data costs. All for free.
Spotify is absolutely free.
You don't have to have a premium account to watch new JRE episodes.
You just need to search for the JRE on your Spotify app.
Go to Spotify now to get this full episode of the Joe Rogan experience.